en este vídeo vamos a cubrir lo que es
posiblemente el único concepto más
importante de toda la estadística y tal
vez lo bueno más bien entra en casi cada
campo científico y es que es el único
concepto más importante de toda la
estadística incluso yo he comentado
algunas personas que es algo un poco
triste que no lo consideren como dentro
de un currículum pues todos deberían de
saber esto porque entra o abarca cada
área o parte de nuestras vidas y estamos
hablando de la distribución normal o
distribución a oceana o la curva de la
campana y solo para darte un avance de
lo que es y bien mi avance de aquí luce
un poco extraño pero conforme avancemos
en el vídeo espero que tengas más
intuición de lo que se trata todo y la
distribución gauss jana o distribución
normal que son diferentes palabras pero
es lo mismo pues fue a causa que se le
ocurrió y creo que él estaba estudiando
un fenómeno astronómico cuando lo hizo
pero es una función de densidad de
probabilidad y hemos estudiado ya la
distribución pues son
y es algo así y solo para darte un
avance de esto donde la probabilidad de
x es la clase de las probabilidades de
las funciones de distribución como la
binomial o la distribución para son
están basadas en varios parámetros pero
esta es igual a y es como
tradicionalmente la base de descrita en
muchos libros de texto y también si
tenemos tiempo me gustaría reordenar el
álgebra que tenemos por aquí para tener
un poco más de intuición de cómo es la
función o tal vez podríamos obtener
algunas ideas de dónde viene esto y no
lo voy a demostrar en este vídeo pues va
más allá de nuestro alcance pero si te
interesa puedes buscar en wikipedia como
la fórmula de stirling la cual podrías
ver que es fascinante pues aproxima
factoriales a funciones continuas
esencialmente pero bueno no me voy a
enfocar en eso ahora y bien la
distribución normal es igual a 1 sobre
esto es como normalmente las escriben
entonces sería 1 sobre la desviación
estándar por la raíz cuadrada de 2 pi
por el ala menos un medio y bien lo voy
a escribir de esta forma pues se me hace
un poco más fácil recordarlo pero bueno
de cualquier forma entonces esto es por
a la menos un medio por equis que es la
variable que estamos buscando menos la
media sobre la desviación estándar al
cuadrado y este término de aquí y si
pensamos en esto aquí hay algo bueno que
nos está diciendo ya que nos está
diciendo qué tan lejos estamos de la
media y lo estamos dividiendo entre la
desviación estándar de dicha
distribución y bueno este es el avance
de la distribución normal que grafique
donde la curva morada es la distribución
normal inicialmente en dicho ejercicio
yo sé que me brinqué un poco todo lo que
estoy tramando pero en sí es para
mostrarte que la distribución normal es
una buena aproximación a la distribución
binomial y viceversa pues si tomas los
suficientes ensayos podrás ver como una
converger a otra y bueno regresando a
este término aquí es realmente
interesante pues nos está diciendo qué
tan lejos estamos de la media
aparte la estamos dividiendo entre la
desviación estándar y es algo que se le
conoce como puntaje z una cosa que
encontré en estadística es que hay
muchas pero muchas definiciones que
suenan un tanto como fantásticas como la
puntuación zeta estándar pero el
concepto es en sí muy sencillo pues
digamos que tengo una distribución de
probabilidad y tomamos algún valor de x
por aquí que podría ser no sé 3.5 3.5 de
desviación estándar a la media
luego la puntuación o el puntaje z
estándar sería 3 y bueno de cualquier
forma concentrémonos en el propósito de
este vídeo así que esto es lo que la
distribución normal tiene por función de
densidad de probabilidad y luce así pero
como llegó hasta allí y bien al final de
este vídeo te sentirás conforme de que
es una buena aproximación a la binomial
al tomar un número suficiente de ensayos
y esto es lo fascinante acerca de
distribución normal es que bueno si tú
tienes
la cual en otro vídeo acerca del teorema
central del límite si tienes la suma de
muchos pero muchos eventos
independientes que están aproximándose a
infinito la distribución de los ensayos
o eventos podrían haber sido normal pero
la distribución de la suma de esos
eventos si se aproximarían a la
distribución normal de lo cual hablaré
más adelante pero esto es una excelente
distribución para suponer algún fenómeno
por ejemplo si estás modelando el clima
o algún comportamiento de medicina
podemos hablar de a cuál se adapta a
línea cuáles no pues algunas veces la
gente podrá suponer cosas con una
distribución normal como las finanzas y
hemos visto que hay crisis financieras
entonces deja demasiadas cosas volando
pero bueno de cualquier forma regresemos
a esto y en realidad esta es sólo una
hoja de cálculo a la televisión fondo
negro y la puedes encontrar en esta
línea que estoy escribiendo por aquí la
cual es importante que lo escribas
completa para que logres encontrarla y
entonces te recomiendo que estés jugando
con ella y tal vez hagas tu otra hoja de
cali
donde experimentes con esto entonces en
esta práctica lo que hicimos es dar un
ejemplo de un juego donde estamos
sentados en la calle y lanzamos una
moneda completamente justa y si tenemos
clara damos un paso hacia atrás o
digamos que a la izquierda y si
obtenemos cruise vamos a dar un paso a
la derecha sale así que en general
tenemos siempre una moneda completamente
injusta por lo que tenemos 50 por ciento
de posibilidades de tomar un paso hacia
la izquierda y un 50% de dar un paso a
la derecha y si de repente te da una
racha de caras que estarás moviendo
mucho hacia la izquierda o si obtienes
un bonche de cruces te estarías moviendo
a la derecha y hemos ya ha aprendido
anteriormente las posibilidades de
obtener bastantes cruces o muchas más
cruces que caras pero es una función que
tiende a hice como siempre igual es
acerca de estar igual y por aquí lo que
he hecho bueno déjame
y me recorro un poco porque no quiero
perder la información así que lo que he
hecho por aquí es que tengo esta pequeña
función y te invito a que lo cambies a
como a ti te guste pues este es el
número de pasos que yo tomé que había
tomado 10 pasos así que como te digo
tomé 10 pasos y tú puedes tomar los que
tú gustes y luego aquí tenemos la media
del número de pasos que se van a la
izquierda y todo lo que hice fue obtener
la probabilidad o las probabilidades y
figurar me en la media de la
distribución binomial y la media de la
distribución es esencialmente la
probabilidad de dar un paso a la
izquierda que lo tome como éxito por el
número total de ensayos lo cual sería
igual a 5 y justo de ahí viene ese
número y la varianza no estoy segura de
si ya hablé de esto antes y si necesito
probarla pero si no lo tengo haré un
vídeo donde haya la varianza de la
binomial pero aquí esencialmente es
igual al número de ensayos o
experimentos que son 10
por la probabilidad de tomar un paso a
la izquierda o de un éxito en este caso
y entonces estoy definiendo la izquierda
como éxito lo cual pudo haber sido
también derecha y pues finalmente en
esta en este ejemplo en este caso tienen
la misma probabilidad de éxito por lo
que por eso es 10 por punto 5 por punto
5 lo cual nos da 2.5 de varianza y es
todo lo que tengo en esta hoja de
cálculos de hecho si pues si quieres
puedes darle clic sobre la celda para
que puedas ver la fórmula con la que lo
hice pues también algunas veces
simplemente ver el excel o la hoja de
cálculo puede ser un poco confuso y este
de aquí es si simplemente es la raíz
cuadrada de aquel número que es la
desviación estándar la cual es la raíz
cuadrada de la varianza así que sea la
raíz cuadrada de 2.5 y ahora si observas
aquí esto esto de aquí es la
probabilidad de que haga cero pasos sale
así que tome el total de pasos que son
los 10 solo para entender esta hoja y
entonces todos los pasos se van a ir
hecha entonces cuál es la probabilidad
de que haya cero pasos a la izquierda y
bien solo para ser más clara si hago
cero pasos a la izquierda me refiero a
que entonces hice los 10 pasos a la
derecha y calculé esta probabilidad y
tal vez debería dibujar esta línea de
aquí
y calculé está utilizando la
distribución binomial lo cual sería para
nuestra binomial serían los pasos
totales que di que son 10 que sería
entonces 10 factorial sobre el número de
pasos que di a la izquierda que son 0
que se hace el factorial por 10 menos
cero factorial cierto esto es eligiendo
cero pasos de los 10 totales que tenemos
a la izquierda y luego esto por la
probabilidad de ir a la izquierda que
sería punto 5 a la 0 que fue 10 pasos
por la probabilidad de los pasos a la
derecha será punto 5 a la 10 y entonces
este resultado de aquí
da 0.001 y viene de justamente este
cálculo y es lo que la distribución
binomial nos dice y este otro
similarmente es 10 factorial sobre 1
factorial por 10 menos 1 factorial que
es lo que nos da otra vez aquí y si das
clic sobre dichas celdas verás esto bien
explicado y así lo hicimos simplemente
con cálculos binomial es llegamos a esto
luego aquí por debajo de esta línea
podríamos simplemente ignorarlo pero lo
hice porque quiero hacer diferentes
escenarios como por ejemplo si vamos a
nuestra hoja de cálculo y lo voy a
cambiar podríamos ponerle que en lugar
de 10 pasos lo hiciéramos con 20 y
entonces esto nos cambia esto esto nos
va a dar un escenario diferente entonces
voy a dejar de pensar por qué pasó esto
tal vez sería bueno que le des una
checada a la hoja de cálculo y lo hagas
en limpio pero bueno no afecta el
gráfico del diagrama de dispersión que
hice y entonces en nuestra gráfica en
azul podemos ver qué
está la binomial y el morado está pero
bueno en realidad no se trata mucho la
diferencia entonces déjame lo hago más
pequeño y sigue sin observarse entonces
vamos a hacerlo ahora con cuatro y aquí
y si se alcanza a identificar un poco
como la gráfica de la binomial queda por
debajo de la normal nada más déjame lo
recalco para que alcanza a distinguirlo
y es justamente aquí donde está nuestra
gráfica de la binomio y como puedes ver
hay sólo algunos puntos aquí que son
como los más importantes por ejemplo si
tomamos seo pasos a la izquierda 1 2 3 4
pasos a la izquierda y luego los gráfica
mos y nos vemos cuál es la probabilidad
de que utilizando la distribución normal
suceda esto y está entonces cuál es mi
posición final de donde sale si todos
los 0 pasos a la izquierda pero tomo 4
la derecha mi posición final es 4 que es
el ese es el escenario justamente de
aquí y déjame cambiarme mi color para
verlo mejor entonces si tomamos cuatro
pasos para listo
y cero pasos a la derecha entonces mi
posición final sería justo la del punto
amarillo que dibujé es cierto entonces
son los diferentes escenarios que
tenemos y si forma si fuéramos más
neutrales y dijéramos que vamos a dar
dos pasos a la izquierda y dos a la
derecha o viceversa entonces tendríamos
nuestro punto más o menos por ahí donde
lo acabo de pintar de color amarillo en
si la distribución binomial luce más
como algo así sería como la probabilidad
de obtener menos 4 luego irnos a menos 2
y así hasta llegar como al punto medio y
la voy a recalcar de color amarillo para
que observes cuál es nuestra gráfica de
la binomial ahora bien lo que estamos
tratando de hacer lo que estoy tratando
de mostrarte es que veas como la la
distribución normal se aproxima a la
binomial sólo que aquí hay algo como un
poco truculento pues la distribución
binomial es una distribución discreta
puedes mirar y obtener esta gráfica y
decir bueno cuál es la probabilidad de
que teniendo exactamente un paso a la
izquierda y 3 a la derecha
ocurra lo siguiente podemos fijarnos en
la tabla que tenemos a la izquierda y
checar los valores que va teniendo cada
paso por ejemplo ahí tenemos encerrados
de este lado en color amarillo lo de dar
dos pasos a la izquierda y dos a la
derecha los cuales serán cero punto 375
cierto lo cual lo ubicamos justamente en
este punto que acabo de señalar y luego
así nos podemos ir fijando qué valores
va teniendo dicha distribución pero
luego entonces lo interesante aquí es
qué pasaría con nuestra distribución
normal como dijimos cuando estábamos
hablando de la distribución binomial es
una distribución discreta entonces
tenemos valores exactos para ciertos
puntos de probabilidad ahora fijándonos
en la distribución normal y como ya lo
habíamos mencionado sería algo
truculento pues aquí nuestra
distribución binomial podemos seguirle
dando las probabilidades de tener cierta
cantidad de pasos a la izquierda oa la
derecha lo cual por ejemplo aquí también
tenemos la parte de tener
y un paso a la izquierda y tres a la
derecha lo cual me pone exactamente aquí
no y bueno observa en esta tabla
volvemos a tomar dicha probabilidad la
cual sería punto 25 la de tener un paso
a la izquierda y 3 a la derecha y es
algo simétrico tenemos punto 25 de un
lado que es 25% de probabilidad de
terminar aquí exactamente en 2 a la
derecha y la distribución normal como
sabemos es una distribución continua lo
cual sería una curva continua y luce
algo así la cual conforme los valores se
aproximan a infinito ésta se aproxima a
0 en ambos lados y luce de esta forma
pero al ser una distribución continua
puedes tomar algún punto aquí y decir
bueno cuál es la probabilidad de que
esté a dos pasos a la derecha si dices
eso la probabilidad de hecho es estar
exactamente en este punto no y para
checar lo mejor podría revisar mis
vídeos de funciones de densidades de
probabilidad pues está exactamente dos
pasos a la derecha estaríamos hablando
como de dos átomos y esto estaría
cercano
de hecho tendrías que especificar un
rango alrededor de esto para poder dar
una probabilidad y lo que asumiremos por
aquí sería tomar como medio pie en ambas
direcciones y estaríamos bueno aquí ya
estaríamos hablando de pies y para
figurar nos lo que hice aquí es tomar el
valor de la función de densidad de la
probabilidad donde evaluamos esto y
luego lo multiplicamos por 1 así que me
da esta área y use esto como
aproximación para dicha área y realmente
quiero ser muy particular con esto lo
que debería hacer es tomar la integral
de esta parte de debajo de la curva en
ese punto y por supuesto que sea una
mejor aproximación pero lo podemos hacer
en un futuro pero ahora lo que quiero es
que tengas la intuición de la
distribución binomial como obtuvimos
estos números de aquí pues bien lo que
podríamos hacer es cuál es la
probabilidad de uno y éste es igual a
uno sobre la desviación estándar donde
la desviación estándar para cuatro pasos
es 1 entonces sería 1 sobre 1
y cambiar esto pues creo que podría
hacer sería mejor cambiarlo a un número
más alto para que tenga más sentido y
digamos que si hago esto tendríamos
entonces 10 regresando al ejemplo de los
10 pasos pero bueno vamos a tener que
cambiar todos nuestros cálculos y déjame
hacerlos bien de hecho tendremos que
tendremos que hacerlos de nuevo entonces
cuál sería la probabilidad que nuestros
ocho pasos restantes fueran dos a la
derecha de los diez pasos entonces ya
nos quedaban aquí ocho y entonces para
los ocho serán seis pasos a la izquierda
cuál sería dicha probabilidad nos está
diciendo que es igual a cero punto cero
41 lo cual nos tiene por aquí más o
menos y sería la probabilidad dar dos
pasos la cual para obtener dicho valor
sería igual a 1 sobre la desviación
estándar la cual es 1.581
la raíz cuadrada de dos pi de hecho
puedes dar clic sobre la celda para
identificar cómo están todos los
cálculos incluso en excel hay una forma
de la distribución de la distribución
normal perdón pero lo que yo quiero es
que te identifiques cómo se hizo cada
uno de los pasos y puedes darle clic a
la celda e identificar cómo se obtuvo
cada uno de los valores y bueno
regresando a nuestro ejemplo teníamos
esta parte de aquí y nos falta
multiplicarlo por ea la menos un medio
para completar nuestra distribución
normal por x menos la media donde aquí x
es el valor que estamos buscando que son
los dos pasos a la izquierda que es
nuestra probabilidad de éxito entonces
sería por dos menos la media aquí la
media para los diez pasos es igual a
cinco entonces será dos menos cinco
sobre la desviación estándar que como
habíamos visto es 1.581 y todo esto al
cuadrado y podrás darte cuenta que si
haces justamente todos estos cálculos
que tenemos por aquí
se alcanza a dar este número que tenemos
de nuestra distribución normal que nos
sitúa más o menos por aquí recuerda que
como estamos hablando de una
distribución continua no nos está dando
exactamente el valor de estar en un
punto sino no se está tomando un rango
de alrededor de dos pies entonces
estaríamos como de 1.5 a 2.5 pies y lo
cual nos sitúa justamente en esa parte
donde únicamente puede pasar si
estuviéramos tomando definitivamente
como muy pequeñitos pasos cada vez más
pequeños pero bueno así es como se
aproxima dicha probabilidad y la manera
de aproximar la es decir bueno cuál es
la probabilidad de comenzar entre el pie
y luego multiplicar la por la altura y
esto que estamos calculando
multiplicarlo por uno pues digamos que
en esta base en la base de esta área es
1 por eso lo multiplicamos por dicha
base para calcular esta área mediante
nuestra aproximación entonces cuando
multiplicamos eso por 1 se obtiene esto
de aquí
y quiero mostrarte que incluso con sólo
10 ensayos la curva de la distribución
normal y la distribución binomial en
azul casi llega a la altura una con otra
y como puedes ver conforme el número de
pasos sea más y más grandes estas casi
convergen en su gráfica una con otra
como se ve en mi hoja de cálculo
de hecho déjame mostrarte cómo convergen
hay una hoja de cálculo si ves en la
parte inferior y le das clic a la
siguiente hoja hay una tabla de
convergencias y es lo mismo solo que
aquí te voy a mostrar cómo convergen y
que pasa con cada punto dado así que
veamos la explicación de esta hoja para
que puedas comprenderla así que esta
probabilidad de aquí son las
probabilidades de moverte a la izquierda
oa la derecha entonces aquí estamos
fijando un punto estamos fijando una
posición en la cual esencialmente aquí
nos está diciendo que si hacemos 10
movimientos esta sería mi posición final
serían 10
entonces mira por aquí tenemos nuestro
total de movimientos en esta primera
parte hay perdón eran movimientos en
esta primera parte eran 10 movimientos
en los cuales 10 a la derecha y cero a
la izquierda luego para 20 movimientos
tenemos 15 a la derecha y 5 a la
izquierda y así hasta llegar por ejemplo
acá 80 movimientos en los cuales son 45
a la derecha y 35 a la izquierda lo cual
nos dan estos 80 movimientos pero
nuestra final posición en nuestra
posición final serían los 10 y aquí
vamos a llegar hasta un total de 170
movimientos donde sería como ya estar
tomando un número infinito de
lanzamientos y quiero que veamos cuál es
la probabilidad de que mi posición final
sean los 10 a la derecha y lo que quiero
mostrarte es que conforme más y más
movimientos tomes la distribución normal
se convierte en una mucho mejor
aproximación a la distribución binomial
así que estos valores de aquí son
cálculos de nuestra distribución
binomial de la forma en como lo hicimos
ya anteriormente entonces podemos ver
qué
muestra nuestro movimiento a la
izquierda es la probabilidad de éxito
así que aquí fueron 0 de 10 movimientos
totales entonces serán 10 en 0 por la
probabilidad de estar ajá por punto 5 de
la probabilidad de estar a la izquierda
que fueron 0 pasos por punto 5 a la 10
que es la probabilidad de los pasos a la
derecha y entonces nos arroja dicho
valor luego por ejemplo si vamos a este
de acá serían 60 movimientos totales
entonces serían los 60 factorial sobre
tenemos 25 movimientos a la izquierda
sobre 25 factorial por 60 menos 25
factoriales por la probabilidad de éxito
que son los movimientos a la izquierda
que sería punto 5 a la 25 por la
probabilidad de la derecha que es la
probabilidad de fracaso por así decirlo
que apuntó 5 a la 35 entonces esto es la
probabilidad de la binomial y nos arroja
dicho valor y así sucesivamente puedes
seguirle haciendo
para figurar no es la media y la
varianza para estas circunstancias
puedes mirar la fórmula pero la media
simplemente la probabilidad de tener
movimiento a la izquierda por el número
total de movimientos y la varianza es la
probabilidad de ir a la izquierda por la
probabilidad de ir a la derecha por el
número total de movimientos y la
probabilidad normal una vez más es
usando la probabilidad de la normal que
es la aproximación a la misma forma por
ejemplo en esta situación en excel está
la distribución normal pero puedes darle
clic a la celda y ver la fórmula que
estamos utilizando entonces aquí
tendríamos que es la probabilidad de 25
hay no perdón que es la probabilidad de
45 que son los pasos que tenemos a la
izquierda y entonces sería igual a 1
sobre la desviación estándar donde la
desviación estándar es la raíz cuadrada
de 25 entonces tendríamos sobre 5 por 2
pib
por lo menos un medio por qué es x que
es 45 menos la media
que 50 sobre la desviación estándar que
es 5 al cuadrado
entonces todo está al cuadrado más bien
y esto es lo que nos dice o nos va a dar
el valor de la distribución normal para
esta situación con esta desviación
estándar y dicha media dada entonces
luego solo multiplicamos por 1 que viene
siendo la base como habíamos comentado y
entonces no lo escribí porque pues es
exactamente lo mismo y esto de aquí nos
va a dar el valor pero para figurar
nuestra probabilidad de iniciar entre un
pie tengo que multiplicar por el uno y
estamos realmente aproximando lo es
decir estamos teniendo aquí como la
integral que aunque era una mejor
aproximación está dándonos otra que es
realmente buena y esta tabla te muestra
el número total de movimientos tan
largos y la diferencia entre la
probabilidad de la normal y la binomial
y muy bien de hecho tú puedes cambiar
este número de aquí y déjame cambiarlo
para mostrarte puedes ver cuál es la
probabilidad de tener 15 movimientos a
la derecha 15 movimientos a la derecha y
podemos poner 12 luego 13
y creo que hay algún pequeño error hay
algo que quizás un pequeño problema con
los números flotantes que están
perdiendo decimales pues tienen que ser
tan largos como como se está marcando
quizás es con los factoriales pero está
pasando algo extraño por aquí también
podemos poner no sé con tres lo voy a
cambiar para ver qué es lo que está
sucediendo
lo ponemos con 3
y qué es lo que pasa con 5
es posible que solo pase para los
números más lejanos pues con 10 podemos
ver que claramente como convergen y
trataré de ver lo que es el problema
pero bueno la idea de tener esta hoja de
cálculo y mostrarte era era
principalmente para que pudieras
observar y te pudieras dar cuenta cómo
iba dándose la convergencia pero bueno
entonces aquí vamos a figurar nos la
probabilidad de iniciar con esos
movimientos a la derecha y conforme
tomes más y más lanzamientos esta
distribución normal se convierte en una
mejor aproximación para nuestra
distribución binomial y conforme te
aproximas van a converger una con otra y
estaré haciendo más vídeos de la normal
puesto que es un concepto muy importante
y creo que haya que aclarar varias cosas